Han Solo: Let's blow
this thing and go home!
Garrett Reisman: "Pwsh!"
Hi, I'm Garrett Reisman,
former NASA astronaut.
And today we're gonna look
at some popular movie clips,
and I'll try to use my experience
as a former director of space operations
at SpaceX and current professor
at University of Southern California, USC,
and give you a rating
on how realistic it is.
Ryan Stone: No, no, no, no!
Gotcha.
Matt Kowalski: You have to
let me go, or we both die.
Stone: I'm not letting you go. We're fine!
Kowalski: No.
Stone: No!
Garrett: Oh, my goodness.
Oh.
Yeah, that was bogus. [laughs]
I really like this movie, despite the fact
that the science, totally wrong.
This movie takes great liberties
and completely blows off
the basic laws of physics.
Kowalski: Man down!
Stone: Copy.
Houston.
Garrett: The movie
deals with space debris,
and that's what causes the calamity
that they then have to
fight the rest of the movie.
This is a real problem,
and it's getting worse.
So, some of the stuff is natural,
but the vast bulk of the flux,
the density of the stuff
whizzing around the Earth,
is created by humans.
It's stuff that we shot up into space,
and we didn't clean up our own mess.
When I was up there, several times
I heard debris hit the space station.
There's certain things in the movie
about how they show the
debris that's not accurate.
You can see it coming in the movie.
They see this, like,
cloud of debris coming
from thousands of kilometers away.
That's bogus, OK?
This stuff is traveling
an order of magnitude
like 10 times faster than a rifle bullet.
You can't look at a shooting range and see
a rifle bullet flying
around from thousands
of kilometers away.
You're not gonna see this stuff coming.
And the other thing about this that's
completely unrealistic: George Clooney
is flying on by, and
Sandra Bullock reaches
and grabs his tether and grabs onto him.
That would be hard.
As he's flying on by, he
would, with his momentum,
try to carry her away and pull her away
from the space station,
and she would have to
resist that and stop him, which she does.
Yay, Sandra Bullock.
You have saved the day.
Well done.
End of story.
It should end right there.
There's no gravity, right,
that's pulling him away.
It's not like she's holding him, like,
over a cliff or something.
He is not pulling her off
the space station anymore.
The work is done.
And once she has stopped his motion
and he's just sitting there,
and she's holding on to the
other end of the tether,
all she has to do is go like this
with her littlest pinky.
"Boop!" And pull him,
and he would be going
right back to the space station,
and they'd be having
a nice lunch together.
He says, "You have to let me go."
Why?
Why does she have to let him go?
And you've got a firm
grip on George Clooney.
You do not let go.
OK? No matter what the
laws of physics say,
you hold on.
Mark Watney: On my way, commander.
Garrett: This whole idea
about puncturing your glove
to fly like Iron Man and be rescued
by your spaceship.
Yeah, not so much.
We have a jet pack that we wear
when we do spacewalks
on the space station.
We needed to have something to do
if you became untethered and started
floating off and you're gonna become lost
in space during a spacewalk.
That's why we added these jet packs.
It's just nitrogen. And
it's just little puffs,
"psh, psh, psh," of nitrogen that come out
of those little jets
is enough to let you fly
back to the space station
and stop you from being lost in space.
Now, first of all, you
would need a spacesuit
pressurized really, really high to get
enough pressure to actually get the kind
of thrust that he gets.
In reality, it's gonna be
a tiny little gentle push.
There's not gonna be a "shh!"
It's gonna be a "pew, pew, pew, pew."
You know, come on.
So that's the first thing that's wrong.
But if you do have this big rocket engine
coming outta your hand, and you're trying
to control yourself, now you've gotta put
that thrust through
your center of gravity.
So you gotta hold it very, very precisely,
and any kind of motion
away from the proper direction
is gonna cause you to start
tumbling out of control.
You're gonna be like, if you
take a balloon and blow it up
and then just release it and it goes
"pbbt" all over the place,
no way you're gonna be, like, "zhhh,"
flying back where you wanna go.
So, bogus, big-time bogus on that.
The rest of the movie
was up, like, a nine.
was really, really good.
Solo: You're all clear, kid.
Now let's blow this thing and go home.
Garrett: The scene in "Star
Wars" where Luke Skywalker
uses the force and destroys the Death Star
by attacking its one hidden weakness.
So, a couple things pop out right away.
One is, you know, what's
with the orange ski goggles
on Luke in the middle of black space?
I mean, really, you need that?
And then, finally, like, Han
Solo's wearing this earpiece
with that microphone thing.
It looks like he's a telemarketer.
He looks like he's trying to sell you
some insurance or something.
But the big thing is they
blow up the Death Star, right,
which is awesome, and it goes "pwsh!"
Now, that wouldn't happen.
I mean, you're not gonna hear anything
because sound needs a
medium to propagate through.
So right now, you're
hearing me talk because
as vibrations go on in my throat
and air goes through that and
the air molecules vibrate,
they vibrate other air molecules,
and because we have air in this room,
it reaches the microphone
and causes vibrations on the microphone.
And then you hear that.
If there's no air here,
But other than that, you
wouldn't be able to hear me.
The thing is that if
you're watching a movie
and you see a big
explosion and it's silent,
it doesn't feel right to the audience.
So I understand why movie editors
and special-effects guys put the sound in,
but it's bogus.
You can see explosions,
and there can be fire,
even in the vacuum of space.
You actually need three things.
You need spark.
You need fuel.
And then you need oxygen
for it to combust.
Then you will see flame,
you will see fire,
even in the vacuum of space.
You won't hear anything,
but you'll see it.
So that is plausible.
Garrett: That McConaughey guy?
He looks just like me, huh?
So, I'd say, obviously, the casting people
know what they're doing.
Cooper: TARS?
TARS: Roger that.
Cooper: Don't you get it yet, TARS?
That's why I'm here.
I'm gonna find a way to tell Murph.
TARS: How, Cooper?
Cooper: The watch.
The watch.
Garrett: Wow, so that
was pretty trippy, huh?
If I remember right from the movie,
he's inside a black hole at this point
where the forces of gravity are so strong
that not even light can escape.
Recently, we got our first
picture of a black hole.
Really, what's around the black hole,
because once light goes
into the event horizon,
the circle around the black hole,
nothing comes out.
But inside the black hole, nobody knows
what happens inside there.
Nothing ever comes back.
If a person went inside a black hole,
what would it really be like?
Who knows?
But you do see the light bending in there,
and it is true that light will bend
when it's exposed to very
strong gravitational fields.
A lot of the stuff that
they did in this movie,
they tried to be as realistic as possible,
but I do have a problem with...
there's this bookshelf tesseract thing.
So, some advanced civilization created
this tesseract where
you go into this thing
and it's, like, lined
with books on the shelf,
and by pulling the books off the shelf,
you could see into other dimensions
and you could communicate to people
in those other dimensions in a very, very
roundabout, incredibly complicated way.
If you're a super-advanced
alien intelligence
that can build a bookshelf tesseract thing
to go across dimensions,
why can't you put in a phone?
Or at least put in, like,
a whiteboard, right?
With a dry-erase marker that
you could just spell, like,
"Hey! Stay away from the black hole!"
You know, whatever, and
send a message that way.
Why do you have to get so complicated?
But other than that, they
got a lot of stuff right,
especially about the relativistic
effects in the movie.
Garrett: This is one of my
all-time favorite space films.
And what's really amazing about it is
how realistic it is
considering they filmed
all of this before Apollo 11,
before we landed men on the moon.
And the science in the movie
holds up tremendously well.
The one thing that's missing there,
and in the opening scene
there, is the atmosphere.
You just see the blue Earth
and then suddenly the black space.
In reality, when you look
at the Earth from space,
there's a thin blue line that separates
the sunlit Earth from
the blackness of space.
So, you might be asking yourself,
why is the space station spinning
and why is it constructed as a big wheel?
What you're doing is you're creating
inertial forces that simulate gravity
and have the same effect.
Because the absence of gravity
causes some problems to the human body.
It causes, for example, some bone loss.
Now, you're up in space,
and you're floating
around like a fish,
and the bones are like,
I guess I don't need
to make any more bone.
Your muscles, especially in
your legs, start to atrophy
'cause you're not using your legs anymore.
You're not walking.
So all kinds of, like,
funky and not-so-good things
happen to your body in space,
so we fight it.
We fight it hard, and
mostly by working out.
We have to do it about
two hours a day every day.
But, hey, what if we can
create artificial gravity?
Then we wouldn't have to do any of this,
and we wouldn't have
any of these problems.
That's the idea behind
the spinning spaceship.
The best way I can explain that is
they had these old amusement park rides
that were like a big washing machine.
You get in, and it starts spinning,
and it throws you up against the wall.
And then the floor drops out,
and you don't fall because you're being
pushed back against a
wall by a pseudo force
we call centrifugal force.
That's what's happening
here in this space station.
By spinning like that, you
can create centrifugal force
that acts and feels
like artificial gravity.
If you're creating artificial
gravity with a small radius,
like those rides in
amusement park that make you
go up against the wall, you can handle
that spinning for a couple minutes.
You don't want to be spending
months in there, right?
You need to avoid having
the radius too small
that you get what's
called Coriolis effects
that makes you kind of dizzy.
You don't want that.
You also need to be spinning fast enough
so that if you walk
the opposite direction,
you don't start floating.
So you have to have a rim speed
that's typically about
6 meters per second,
which is bigger than your
average person walks.
So, a lot of times in the movies,
either it's not long enough
or it's spinning too slow
for it to really do its job.
Does "2001" get it right?
Yes, it does.
If you look at that thing
and you time the rate of the rotation
and you try to estimate how big it is,
the radius is about 150 meters,
and it's spinning at about 1 1/2 rpm.
That's enough to get you almost half a G.
So almost half the gravity
that you feel on Earth,
which is probably good enough.
So that's not bad.
If those numbers are accurate.
Which, I kinda made it up, so, you know.
But I think we're close.
Rocket: Quill, don't be ridiculous.
Get back into your pod!
You'll die in seconds!
Garrett: Hey, look, any
movie with a talking raccoon
is OK in my book.
Oh, boy.
[laughs] OK.
First of all, it's great that he's got
this mask on so he can breathe in space,
but what about the rest of his body?
The rest of your body is gonna be
in really, really bad shape.
The fluids inside your
tissues is gonna vaporize,
and so basically, your
blood is gonna boil,
all the water in your tissue
is gonna turn into gas.
He takes off his helmet to try to save
his friend there,
somehow holds his breath.
Now, it's true that you can survive
for very brief periods of time
while exposed to a vacuum.
It has been done.
There's been accidents on
Earth in vacuum chambers,
and if you get quickly back down
to regular pressure, you're gonna be OK.
But there's a couple
things you worry about.
The first thing you have
to worry about: barotrauma.
So, what that means is that there's gas
inside your body, in your lungs,
in your sinuses, and that's gonna start
expanding once you get
exposed to a vacuum,
'cause now, instead of having the outside
air pressure to work against,
now there's nothing out here.
It's gonna want to blow up like a balloon.
Then you worry about
decompression sickness,
where all the nitrogen comes out
of the solution in your blood,
what scuba divers can get when they
spend too much time at depth
and come up too quickly.
They call it "the bends" 'cause you
bend over in pain at all your joints
where the bubbles build up.
So all that would happen to Star-Lord
even before he takes off his mask.
Having said that, did I mention
that this movie has a talking raccoon?
You're worried about the helmet?
I mean, it's got a talking raccoon.
Garrett: True story, I use this
clip in my class here at USC
when I was teaching this
subject about what happens
if you do get exposed to
vacuum, and I tell people
we actually have a test
subject that volunteered,
and at NASA we did an experiment,
and we have video of that
experiment, and here it is.
And I show that clip, and they
get a good laugh out of it.
'Cause, no, that's not
really terribly accurate.
What would happen if you're exposed
to space and were not
adequately protected,
and that is when parts of your body,
parts of your tissues,
the liquid vaporizes,
turns into a gas and you
puff up like a balloon.
Presumably, that would happen
around your face as well,
but it wouldn't look exactly like that.
That's a little Hollywood
magic right there.
Another thing about this clip
is that he hits a rock
and the visor shatters,
and you hear it shatter like it's glass.
Most spacesuit helmets are
made out of polycarbonate,
which is much tougher.
It wouldn't shatter quite like that.
You can break your space helmet,
and so tumbling down a surface on Mars
and whacking your head into a rock
is not recommended.
Barf: No, we're losing power!
Starr: Why?
Barf: 'Cause we're outta gas!
Starr: OK, we'll have to set her down.
Prepare for an emergency landing.
Garrett: I can't believe you
actually want me to comment
on the scientific realism of "Spaceballs."
They're flying around space in a Winnebago
with a dogman as your second in command,
and, really, you want me to
talk about whether or not
it violates the laws of physics.
Where do I start?
First issue is if you're traveling
in between planets, even
between solar systems
in the future, so, once
you're on your trajectory,
you're not burning your engines anymore.
For example, when we went to the moon,
we got into Earth orbit,
we lit the engines up
to get enough velocity
to escape Earth orbit,
and get on a trajectory
going towards the moon.
But that only lasted minutes.
And then, once we had that velocity
and we were heading in the right direction
at the right speed, we
shut the engines down,
and you coast.
So, if you run out of gas, you don't fall
out of the sky. [laughs]
You're going to continue coasting
in the same direction and the same
trajectory you had before.
But, again, you know,
it's a Winnebago. [laughs]
So what do you want me to tell you?
Anyway, if you can accept all that
and you run out of fuel, now
you fall, which is wrong.
And now you have to
crash-land on this planet,
and it's a desert.
That can happen. You know,
Earth has got deserts.
Obviously, Earth is a planet.
Mars and the moon both have
a lot of sand-like soil
we call regolith, so it's not unrealistic
that if you came down on a planet
that there would be a
desert with lots of sand.
Spock: Gravity systems
are failing. Hold on.
Scotty: There won't be time for evacuation
if we don't get power to
stabilize the d--- ship!
Kirk: Scotty, we've got to get
the power back on, come on!
Garrett: When you're way out in the future
and you're, like, "Star
Trek" time, super-advanced
with photon torpedoes
and phasers and stuff
and green women, you can just speculate
that you've got some advanced technology.
So, in the "Star Trek" world, we just have
gravity plate that is degrading,
according to Spock in this clip,
and you can just wave
your hands and do that.
The thing about that is,
so, let me tell you a story.
I was up on the space station,
and when you're up on the space station,
they ask you, "Would you
like to talk to anybody,"
like, any celebrities
or interesting people.
And they do that as
kind of a morale boost.
So I said, "Yeah, I would like to talk to
Ron Moore and David Eick."
They are the people that
created "Battlestar Galactica."
We had this video teleconference,
and I said to them, "You
know, you did the same thing.
You come up with this
artificial gravity on Galactica.
Everybody's just walking
around like they're on Earth,
but you're out in the middle of space.
Where's the gravity coming from?
Why do you have to do that?
Like, why would you take
away one of the coolest
things about being up
here, the ability to fly?"
And Ron Moore said to me, he said,
"Garrett...you have any idea how expensive
those special effects are
and all those stunts?"
So I get why, especially
if you're doing something
like "Battlestar Galactica" or "Star Trek"
that you'd want to just
say oh, artificial gravity.
So I'm not gonna knock "Star Trek" down.
News anchor: The deadly
CO2 gas is literally
poisoning the astronauts
with every breath in and out.
Control: OK, we have an
unusual procedure for you here.
Fred Haise: They want you
to rip the cover off the
flight plan.
Jack Swigert: With pleasure.
Control: All right, now, the
other materials you're gonna
need here are two lithium
hydroxide canisters,
duct tape.
You want to cut the duct tape 3 feet long.
Swigert: Houston, filter's in place.
Garrett: So, yes, that really happened.
They had a big challenge because they had
to find some way of scrubbing
out the carbon dioxide
inside the command module of Apollo 13
without having it powered up.
So, humans make carbon dioxide.
We consume oxygen.
We breathe out carbon dioxide.
And if that gets too
high, bad things happen.
You get headaches,
and eventually you can even die
if the carbon dioxide levels get too high.
Now, on Earth we have a wonderful thing,
it's called plants [laughs],
that do this for us.
And during Apollo 13,
or in any spacecraft,
you have to somehow accomplish
it without having plants.
And so we use a chemical
called lithium hydroxide.
It absorbs the CO2, but you use it up.
Like, on the space
shuttle, we had to change
out the canisters of LiOH,
lithium hydroxide, every so often.
So they couldn't use the equipment
inside the command module that normally
takes all the carbon
dioxide that we spew out
and sucks that and scrubs
that out of the air.
John Young: There's been an explosion.
Oxygen tanks are gone,
two fuel cells gone,
command module's shut down.
News anchor: And astronauts Jim Lovell,
Fred Haise, and Jack Swigert are making
their way through the
tunnel to the lunar module,
using it as a lifeboat so they'll have
electrical power for their radios
on the command module.
Garrett: They had to
find some way to do it
using the lunar lander,
which wasn't intended
to be used for that period
of time for three people.
News anchor: With each
breath, the three men expel
more of the poisonous gas
into the lunar module cockpit,
and the scrubbers intended to
keep the atmosphere breathable
are quickly becoming saturated.
Garrett: They had to use
some of the canisters
from the command module.
The thing was, the command module
and the lunar module were made
by two different companies.
Because they were two different companies,
they actually made them
two different shapes.
So one was round, and one was square.
Well, they came up with
a pretty good plan,
which was that they made an adapter
by using the cardboard or the cover
of the flight plan, some duct tape,
and some hose, and they found a way to
make an adapter to use
this square peg in the round hole.
That's really the workaround
that they came up with, and it worked.
And so what you see in
that movie is 100% real.
They even used actual dialog.
You know, NASA recorded
all the transmissions
to and from the spaceship
and on the intercom,
and so they had transcripts of what
actually happened during
the real Apollo 13.
[alarm buzzing]
Swigert: Hey, we've got a problem here.
Control: Uh, this is Houston.
Say again, please.
Jim Lovell: Houston, we have a problem.
Garrett: "Apollo 13" is the gold standard.
They got it right more than probably any
other movie ever made about space.
This movie is the closest
thing to being a documentary
without actually taking cameras
up and filming it in space.
Stephen Colbert: I've heard that you,
in space, no one can hear you scream.
Would you test that for me right now?
Could you scream for us?
Garrett: Sure, Stephen, I'd be happy to.
[audience laughing]
Colbert: It's true!
It's true!
No one can hear you scream!